computer security is an absolutely
fascinating field it's a lot of fun to
work on and it's a problem that's only
getting worse
as time goes by because more of our data
is available online hello my name is Dan
Boneh I'm a professor of computer
science and electrical engineering here
at Stanford University I'm also
co-director of the computer security lab
and I teach many courses on computer
security all of which counts towards the
cyber security graduate certificates
computer security is an extremely
important area for our graduates to be
familiar with when they build software
out in the real world it's absolutely
vital that they understand the security
impacts of everything they write
industry is kind of desperate for talent
in computer security it's an absolutely
fundamental and crucial part of computer
security education and we take it very
seriously when we teach our class we're
at the heart of Silicon Valley where all
these companies are around us when we
want to talk about computer security
with Google or with Facebook it's really
easy to just get in the car and go meet
with with our colleagues and those
companies I think the importance of
computer security has kind of shot up in
the last couple of years tremendously
there are constantly attacks on computer
systems we all hear about breaches data
theft IP theft all happening on a daily
basis all of that has really focused
everybody's attention on computer
security and as a result there's also a
lot of interest everybody wants to learn
computer security
we cannot graduate students fast enough
the graduates of the cybersecurity
graduate program all go work in industry
and develop products often the work as
program managers developers they write a
lot of code that actually ships in
products upon successful completion of
four courses you will receive your
Stanford certificate Stanford is
actively working to address the world's
cybersecurity needs it's an exciting
time to study with us and gain vital
skills needed for today's cyber
workforce